تونس لها كم يوم من السلطه مشغوله بسبب
اغنيه ساخره اغنيه وصلت للنيابه والقضاء
والرئاسه وفتحت نقاشات على اعلى المستويات
الاغنيه اطلقها شابين اسمهم يوسف شلبي
وضياء نصير عمرهم 26 و 27 سنه وهم من
محافظه نابل شمال شرق تونس والاغنيه
الساخره اسمها بابا في الليل يلوش في
الاقليم والاغنيه بتنتقد سلوك الشرطه
وقانون استهلاك المخدرات وكلماته على
الحان اغنيه كرتون بابار الشهير والاغنيه
انتشرت من هنا وانقبض على الشابين من هنا
بحيينا
كنا تحليل اولاد الكل مصدومين يقلص لك
تمنين قتلو الامامي
[موسيقى]
على
[تصفيق]
ما يعرف
مره في حينا
الشبان اللي بيغنوا الاغنيه انقبض عليهم
وهم طالعين من مقهى بعد ما اعتبر عناصر في
شرطه نابل انه الاغنيه فيها اساءه للغير
ونشر امور غير صحيحه عن موظف عمومي ومع
انتشار خبر القبض عليهم انتفضت المنصات
غضب وتنديد باعتقال الشباب خاصه من قبل
الناس اللي شايفه انهم ما عملوا شيء
والاغنيه ساخره وناس تانيه بتقول فين حريه
التعبير وشباب اطلقوا حمله اسمها سيب
الشباب يعني فلتو الشباب حمله الانتقادات
هذه للقبض على الشباب استجابه لها وزاره
الداخليه اللي اعلن الناطق الرسمي باسمها
ان الوزير امر بفتح بحث اداري حول عمليه
توقيف الشباب للتثبت في حيثياتها وبعد
الرئيس بنفسه قيس سعيد طلع في تصريحات وقف
فيها لجانب الشعب والشباب وانتقد فيها
اعتقالهم
شديد الاستغراب من اعتقالي عدد من
التلاميذ او الطلبه بناء
لا اتدخل في القضاء ولكن لا اريد ان يظلم
احد في هذه البلاد
نحترم القضاء ولكن نحترم القضاء المستقل
ليس هناك اي مبرر على الاطلاق
لاعتقال طلبه وهم يستعدونه لاجراء
الامتحانات لما حصل غير مقبول وعلى القضاه
الشرفاء ان يتصدوا لمثل هذه التجاوزات
وعلى المجلس الاعلى للقضاء ان يقوم بدوره
كاملا في
ضمان العدل لكل التونسيين من نهب الدوله
ومن نهبوا المجتمع خارج السجون ومن
كان في بيته ورددوا اغنيه ما هو السبب
للاعتقال حتى على افتراض انهم
قاموا بجرم على اقتراض
لماذا الاحتفاظ بهم
لماذا التنكير بهم
هذه الرساله واضحه لاننا اننا لن نسكت
ابدا عن الظالمين
ولن نسكت ابدا عن حقوق المظلومين
واخر تطورات القضيه انه من اقل من ساعتين
اعلن فريق الدفاع عن الشابين الافراج عنهم
[موسيقى]